la préparation c'est tout simple donc
notre carburant principal c'est ici vous
avez les bouillards d'eau chaude
puisquon a besoin d'eau chaude pour
faire du café et pour faire des Soues 5
6 7 8 des températures négatives qui
durent et rendent la vie dans la rue
encore plus difficile ce soir là l'é
mararodeur de la Croix Rouge de
l'antenne viroflet véis s'organise on a
pris un sac poubelle ou pas ou on va
préparer différentes choses donc on va
préparer du sucre des petites cuillères
on va préparer des des des kit hygiènes
si les gens nous demandent des brosses à
dents des rasoirs des choses comme ça on
a on a un peu de quoi leur donner et
puis on prend toujours quelques boîtes
de gâteau le 8 janvier dernier le préfet
des ivelin a activé le plan grand froid
conséquence l'antenne a rajouté deux
équipes de bénévoles et une de salarié
chaque soir en ce moment on a au lieu
d'avoir tris ou quatre équipes qui
tournent en tout on en a plutôt 7 ou h
ça permet de faire des maraudes qu'on
appelle des marudes exploratoires qu'on
se promène vraiment dans les villes on
va là où on nous appelle mais on va
aussi se promener dans les endroits où
on sait que parfois il y a des gens qui
sont pour pour voir s'ils ont s'ils ont
besoin de nous le groupe de bénévoles
appelle la régulatrice tout le long de
la maraude pour qu'elle les tiennent
informé des appels de détresse les gens
appelle le
115 le 115 appelle la régule et nous on
appelle la régule donc il nous donne des
ce qu'on appelle des mission et si
jamais il y a plus de mission B on on
fait un peu le tour dans versaill à des
endroits où on sait que potentiellement
il y a
quelqu'un vous voulez quelque chose un
pull des gants non ah c'est la propos de
manger chaque jour je rappelle 115 pour
manger j'appelle 115 pour 4h puis il m'
porte manger ici la soupe devient
souvent un prétexte pour rentrer en
contact avec ces hommes et ses femmes
les membres de l'association profitent
de cet échange pour orienter le
bénéficiaire vers un centre d'ébergement
ou une préfecture C personnes ont été
accompagnées par l'équipe ce soirl ce
soir on a on a très peu de gens on a on
a vu quelques personnes qui fait très
froid et le plan grand froid a été
déclenché donc il y a plus de gens qui
ont été mis à l'abri il y a plus de
place disponible et et puis quand il
fait très froid les gens ils se ils se
mettent dans des parkings ils trouvent
des endroits pour se mettre à l'abri le
plan grand froid est toujours activé des
températures plus clémentes sont attendu
pour mercredi 17 janvier avant de
rechuter jeudi les prévisions annoncent
Mo- 3 degrés à Versailles on a du
canard